Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢您收听《历史余温》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你只能报个假名，比如咖啡馆的名字“朱莉娅”。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己像是在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca Thursday, 19th. Into PM, had fresh gales at South Southwest and cloudy, squally weather with a large, southerly sea. At six, took into topsails and at one a.m. brought to and sounded but had no ground with 130 fathoms of line.
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。19 日，星期四。下午，南偏西南风，有新鲜大风，天气多云，阵雨，海面有大浪。六点，收起顶帆，凌晨一点，船只停航并测深，但 130 英寻的测深绳未触底。
At five, set to topsails close-reefed. At six, saw land extending from northeast to west, distance five or six leagues, having 40 fathoms, fine sandy bottom. To southernmost point of land we had in sight, which bore from us west a quarter south, I judged to lay in the latitude of thirty-six degrees, zero minutes south, and into longitude of two hundred and eleven degrees, seven minutes west,
五点，挂起缩帆后的顶帆。六点，看到陆地从东北延伸至西，距离五到六里格，水深 40 英寻，海底为细沙。我判断我们所见陆地的最南端，位于我们西偏南四分之一处，纬度为南纬 36 度 0 分，经度为西经 211 度 7 分，
from to meridian of Greenwich. I've named it Point Hicks because Lieutenant Hicks was the first who discovered this land. Now, Tom, that's an authentic audio archive, isn't it, of Captain Cook, stalwart Yorkshireman. I mean, he sounds a fascinating conversationalist. Who wouldn't want to spend three years in a cabin listening to him talk like that? Yeah. So for those people who like football,
以格林威治子午线为准。我将其命名为希克斯角，因为希克斯中尉是第一个发现这片土地的人。汤姆，这可是库克船长的真实音频档案，对吧？这位坚定的约克郡人。我的意思是，他听起来是一位迷人的谈话者。谁不想在船舱里待上三年，听他那样说话呢？是的。所以对于那些喜欢足球的人来说，
he was a man very like Neil Warnock, the erstwhile manager of every championship team. Tom, I know you don't know who Neil Warnock is. I've got no idea. I was thinking more like Michael Parkinson, the late, great Michael Parkinson. Right. Or Dickie Bird, the umpire.
他就像尼尔·沃诺克，那位曾执教过每一支冠军球队的前任主教练。汤姆，我知道你不知道尼尔·沃诺克是谁。我完全不知道。我当时想的是迈克尔·帕金森，那位已故的伟大人物迈克尔·帕金森。对。或者板球裁判迪基·伯德。
Dickie Bird, yes, who wears a flat white leather cap. Okay. So listen, this is Captain Cook, Tom. Yeah. This is the moment when he first sees Australia. It's from his journal entry on Thursday, the 19th of April, 1770. Now, I was tempted to say this is the moment when Captain Cook discovered Australia. That's what I would have said as a schoolboy. That would be a schoolboy howler.
迪基·伯德，是的，他戴着一顶平顶白皮帽。好吧。听着，这就是库克船长，汤姆。是的。这是他第一次看到澳大利亚的时刻。摘自他 1770 年 4 月 19 日星期四的航海日志。我曾想说这是库克船长发现澳大利亚的时刻。如果我是个小学生，我肯定会这么说。那将是一个小学生才会犯的低级错误。
It would be a schoolboy error. So tell me why Captain Cook did not discover Australia, please. Put me right. Well, first of all, Dominic, the indigenous peoples of Australia discovered Australia many tens of thousands of years before. But also, hadn't Abel Tasman or somebody had turned up beforehand? He had sailed round it, but in an incompetent manner, I think, compared with Cook. He hadn't done the eastern bit of Australia, which is crucial. I mean, what we should be saying is that the reason we're doing Captain Cook is because he is an example of a plucky Englishman going south, down under, to explore the beautiful landscapes of New Zealand and Australia.
那将是一个小学生才会犯的错误。所以请告诉我，为什么库克船长没有发现澳大利亚？纠正我一下。好吧，首先，多米尼克，澳大利亚的原住民在几万年前就已经发现了澳大利亚。而且，难道阿贝尔·塔斯曼或者其他人之前没有出现过吗？他确实绕着它航行过，但我认为他比库克航行得更不专业。他没有完成澳大利亚东部的探索，而那才是关键。我的意思是，我们之所以要讲库克船长，是因为他是勇敢的英国人南下，前往新西兰和澳大利亚探索美丽风景的典范。
Yeah. And Dominic, that is what we're going to be doing, isn't it? Well, Captain Cook was very much about opening up intellectual horizons as well as geographical ones. And that's exactly what we'll be doing in Australia, Tom. Yes. So this is a New Zealand and Australian inspired couple of episodes on Captain Cook's first voyage down under. He discovers, well, he doesn't discover, does he?
是的。多米尼克，这正是我们要做的，不是吗？嗯，库克船长不仅在地理上，在智力视野上也极大地拓宽了人们的认知。这正是我们在澳大利亚要做的，汤姆。是的。所以这是关于库克船长第一次南下航行的两集节目，灵感来自新西兰和澳大利亚。他发现了，好吧，他并没有发现，对吧？
Yes. He did it again. Well, he does discover a number of islands kind of dotted around the Pacific in due course. But yes, he visits New Zealand and Australia and this is what we're doing today. So hooray. Captain Cook is a controversial figure, Tom, of course. He's become a symbol of colonialism to some people. And yet, he's a very rich subject of study because he's emblematic of 18th century England, of the Enlightenment, of the Age of Discovery, of the Scientific Revolution,
是的。他又来了。好吧，他确实在太平洋各处发现了一些岛屿。但没错，他访问了新西兰和澳大利亚，这就是我们今天要讲的内容。太棒了。汤姆，库克船长当然是一个有争议的人物。对某些人来说，他已成为殖民主义的象征。然而，他是一个非常丰富的研究课题，因为他是 18 世纪英国、启蒙运动、大航海时代、科学革命的象征，
and of this sort of spirit of, you know, there are dark sides to his story, of course, and we'll get into those. But I think Captain Cook is a brilliant window to talk about the mentality of the last sort of third of the 18th century, don't you? Well, Dominic, you will well know that I didn't want to do this at all. And I didn't want to do it for two reasons. The first was I thought that Captain Cook had been cancelled and that we'd be straying into sensitive territory. And I didn't really know anything about him. So to be clear, cowardice.
以及那种精神，你知道的，他的故事当然也有阴暗面，我们会深入探讨。但我认为库克船长是一个绝佳的窗口，可以用来探讨 18 世纪最后三分之一时期的心态，你不觉得吗？嗯，多米尼克，你很清楚我根本不想做这个。我不想做有两个原因。第一个是我认为库克船长已经被“取消”了，我们可能会进入敏感领域。而且我对他一无所知。所以说清楚点，就是懦弱。
Cowardice. Yeah. Yes, pure funk. But also, I just thought he seemed really boring. No, you did that just because you hate Yorkshire, because you look down on Yorkshiremen. No, no. So the Lady Bird books, books that schoolboys and girls in the 1970s and 80s read,
懦弱。是的，纯粹的胆怯。但我也觉得他看起来真的很无聊。不，你这么说只是因为你讨厌约克郡，因为你瞧不起约克郡人。不，不。所以“瓢虫丛书”，那是 20 世纪 70 年代和 80 年代小学生们读的书，
you know, great British heroes and things like that. There was one on Captain Cook and I never read it because I found it so boring. It was the worst, actually. It was one of the worst. It was absolutely the worst. Insufficient quantity of fighting for an eight-year-old reader, I would say. Right. Because basically, oh, it just goes around. Here's another island and, oh, there's Australia. And it just kind of goes on like that. And nothing much seems to happen. And then I read, you know, I kind of sat down and read a biography of him.
你知道，伟大的英国英雄之类的。里面有一本关于库克船长的，我从来没读过，因为我觉得太无聊了。实际上它是最差的。它是绝对最差的。对于一个八岁的读者来说，打斗场面严重不足，我会这么说。对。因为基本上，哦，他只是到处转。这是另一个岛，哦，那是澳大利亚。事情就是这样继续下去的。似乎没发生什么大事。然后我读了，你知道，我坐下来读了他的传记。
And that just seemed really boring. Tom, we're meant to be selling the episode. There are probably people switching off at this moment. I know. And, you know, there was lots of kind of rope and spinnakers and, well, you know, top sales. All the stuff that you were reading out in the opening. Fathoms of line. Fathoms of line. Sandy bottoms. But then I read a whole series of stuff that actually opened my
那看起来真的很无聊。汤姆，我们是来推销这期节目的。现在可能有人正在关掉节目。我知道。而且，你知道，有很多绳索和球帆，还有，嗯，你知道，顶帆。所有你在开场白里读到的东西。英寻长的绳索。英寻长的绳索。沙质海底。但后来我读了一系列的东西，它们真的让我大开
eyes and it will astound you to know that I'm now a complete Captain Cook fan. And I've been going around just telling everyone what an amazing story it is. It's full of great stuff and I'm all over it. I love it. Great. You're reviewing your own podcast before you've even done it. No, I'm all over Captain Cook. I mean, you're reviewing your contribution. This podcast may be terrible.
眼界，你会惊讶地发现，我现在完全成了库克船长的粉丝。我到处告诉别人这是一个多么了不起的故事。它充满了精彩的内容，我完全沉浸其中。我喜欢它。太好了。你还没做节目就在评论你自己的播客了。不，我完全沉浸在库克船长的故事里。我的意思是，你在评论你自己的贡献。这个播客可能会很糟糕。
That would not be the fault of Captain Cook because I agree. It is brilliant. It's brilliant in the way that I found that Nelson was brilliant because basically this is, I mean, it is about the voyage of exploration. So I read a wonderful book by an Australian scholar, Nicholas Thomas, who I think his focus is on the cultures of Oceania, so all the Pacific islands and so on. But he wrote a wonderful book called Discoveries, The Voyages of Captain Cook. And he describes Cook as he's still commonly regarded as the greatest sea explorer of all time.
那不会是库克船长的错，因为我同意。这很精彩。它精彩的方式和我发现纳尔逊精彩的方式一样，因为基本上，我的意思是，这是关于探索航行的。所以我读了一位澳大利亚学者尼古拉斯·托马斯写的精彩著作，我认为他的研究重点是大洋洲的文化，也就是所有的太平洋岛屿等等。但他写了一本名为《发现：库克船长的航行》的精彩书籍。他将库克描述为至今仍被公认为史上最伟大的海上探险家。
I think that I didn't properly realize how and why it is that Cook deserves that accolade. But also on top of that, as you said, he is a kind of emblematic figure of the Enlightenment. And just as the ships in Nelson's Navy are kind of floating embodiments of the 19th century in an 18th century sea, there is absolutely a sense in which, I mean, there is something of science fiction about this. It's kind of like a spaceship hovering over New York or something like that. The sense that Cook, and part of the reason why he's become a controversial figure, I think is nothing to do with Cook himself. Cook himself, it seems to me, an estimable character.
我想我之前并没有真正意识到库克为何以及如何配得上这一赞誉。而且最重要的是，正如你所说，他是一种启蒙运动的象征性人物。就像纳尔逊海军中的船只一样，它们是 18 世纪大海上 19 世纪的浮动化身，这绝对有一种科幻小说的感觉。就像一艘宇宙飞船悬停在纽约上空之类的。那种感觉，库克，我认为他成为争议人物的原因与库克本人无关。在我看来，库克本人是一个值得尊敬的人物。
Following this, we're going to be doing eight episodes on the conquest of the Aztecs. So Hernan Cortes, the Spanish conquistador. Now, Cortes, he's a wanker. I mean, he's a horrible man. I can't believe you went there. Wow. To read about Captain Cook after reading about Cortes, you think, this is an admirable man. I think he is an admirable man in many ways, but he embodies the tensions and the complexities of
接下来，我们将制作八集关于征服阿兹特克人的节目。也就是埃尔南·科尔特斯，那位西班牙征服者。现在，科尔特斯，他是个混蛋。我的意思是，他是个可怕的人。我不敢相信你竟然这么说。哇。在读完科尔特斯之后再读库克船长，你会觉得，这是一个令人钦佩的人。我认为他在许多方面确实是一个令人钦佩的人，但他体现了
the Enlightenment and its relationship with the broader world. Because the Enlightenment claims to be universal, but of course, it's coming from a very culturally contingent place. It's coming from Europe and Europeans going out and discovering things. Hence the sensitivity around discovery because there are lots of people who, of course, they're already there. The interaction of this great European project of enlightenment with the incredible cultures that Cook visits on the way is fascinating. It's an amazing story. Yeah. To be fair to Cook, one of the things that's fascinating about his story is the way that he outgrows that Enlightenment perspective.
启蒙运动及其与更广阔世界关系的张力和复杂性。因为启蒙运动声称是普世的，但当然，它来自一个文化上非常偶然的地方。它来自欧洲，来自欧洲人走出去发现事物。因此围绕“发现”这个词的敏感性，因为当然，那里已经有很多人了。这种伟大的欧洲启蒙项目与库克在途中访问的不可思议的文化之间的互动非常迷人。这是一个了不起的故事。是的。公平地说，库克故事中迷人的一点是他超越了那种启蒙视角的方式。
You can see his character and his kind of intellectual frameworks developing and growing. Okay. Listeners will be very disappointed, Tom, if I didn't point out the key difference between Captain Cook and Hernán Cortés is, of course, that Cook is British. Yes. But let's actually talk about that. So Cook is a, he's aorkshireman isn't he his father is scottish by birth from the borders from kelso yes very near my scottish estate yeah i knew
你可以看到他的性格和他的知识框架在发展和成长。好吧。听众会很失望的，汤姆，如果我不指出库克船长和埃尔南·科尔特斯之间的关键区别，当然，库克是英国人。是的。但让我们来谈谈这个。所以库克是，他是约克郡人，不是吗？他的父亲是苏格兰人，出生在边境地区的凯尔索。是的，就在我的苏格兰庄园附近。是的，我知道
as soon as i said that i thought oh here we go the scottish estate and and sure enough there it was it has an excellent marketplace with a lovely bookshop and a tweed shop kelso i've heard of the kelso bookshop actually and a And a beer shop. Very good. So James Cook Senior, he moved in the middle of the 18th century, or the early part of the 18th century, I should say, down towards Cleveland in North Yorkshire. He meets a girl called Grace. They get married. And their son, James, James Junior, their second son, is born in 1728. And his father is a labourer, a farm labourer, basically. So unlike Nelson, the other great British maritime hero, Cook's background could hardly
我一说出口就想，哦，开始了，苏格兰庄园，果然如此。那里有一个很棒的市场，有一家可爱的书店和一家粗花呢店，凯尔索，我其实听说过凯尔索书店。还有一家啤酒商店。非常好。所以老詹姆斯·库克，他在 18 世纪中期，或者我应该说是 18 世纪早期，搬到了北约克郡的克利夫兰附近。他遇到了一个叫格蕾丝的女孩。他们结婚了。他们的儿子，詹姆斯，小詹姆斯，他们的第二个儿子，出生于 1728 年。他的父亲是一名劳工，基本上是农场劳工。所以与另一位伟大的英国海上英雄纳尔逊不同，库克的背景几乎
be more humble. Incredibly humble. Yeah. And what's so, in a way, kind of inspiring about his story is that Thomas, in his book, says that he could have vanished among the marine proletariat as common men soon afterwards could vanish into the factories of Manchester and Leeds. So he is someone who could have been part of the kind of the muscle and the victims of the industrial revolution that is kind of brewing at this time, incubating. Absolutely. But it seems that the local kind of lord of the manor or whatever saw qualities in
不能再卑微了。极其卑微。是的。而且他的故事在某种程度上令人鼓舞的是，托马斯在他的书中说，他本可能消失在海事无产阶级中，就像不久后普通人会消失在曼彻斯特和利兹的工厂里一样。所以他是一个本可能成为当时正在酝酿、孵化中的工业革命的劳动力和牺牲品的人。绝对是。但似乎当地的庄园主还是什么人看到了他身上的品质。
him. He was a bright boy, clearly, and paid for him to attend the village school. Clearly, his father was highly thought of in the community. When Cook was about 17, I mean, his early life is pretty obscure, isn't it? And actually, throughout, we struggle sometimes, I think, to get a view of Cook's inner life because he's a... Reserved man, isn't he? Yeah, he's a stereotypical Yorkshireman, actually. He's quite taciturn, very self-disciplined, a man who believes in rigour and order. Well, you could see from the journal that you read, I mean, that's not a huge insight into
他显然是个聪明的孩子，并出钱让他上了村里的学校。显然，他的父亲在社区里备受推崇。库克大约 17 岁时，我的意思是，他早年的生活相当模糊，不是吗？实际上，自始至终，我认为我们有时很难了解库克的内心世界，因为他是一个……沉默寡言的人，不是吗？是的，他实际上是一个典型的约克郡人。他相当沉默寡言，非常有自律性，一个相信严谨和秩序的人。好吧，你可以从你读的日志中看出来，我的意思是，那对他
his emotions and feelings in that. No, no, not at all. He's laid eyes on what he thinks may be a new continent, and he's all about the fathoms and the line and stuff. Anyway, he moves to a place when he's a teenager called Stades on the North Yorkshire coast, not far from Whitby, and he works as an apprentice in a village shop. So at this point, you know, a glittering future does not await. Well, he has nothing to do with the sea, does he? I mean, that's the salient fact. He's behind a counter. Exactly. He is behind a counter.
的情感和感受并没有太多的洞察。不，完全没有。他看到了他认为可能是新大陆的东西，而他关心的全是英寻、绳索之类的东西。总之，他十几岁时搬到了北约克郡海岸的一个叫斯泰兹的地方，离惠特比不远，他在一家村店当学徒。所以此时，你知道，辉煌的未来并没有在等待他。好吧，他与大海毫无关系，不是吗？我的意思是，这是一个显著的事实。他在柜台后面。没错。他在柜台后面。
Indeed, he's sleeping under the counter because he doesn't even have a room. And there's an extraordinary story, one of these foundational legends, that a woman customer has when she pays for her goods. One of the coins is an unusually shiny shilling, which is a South Sea shilling minted in the reign of George I, with the South Sea Company stamped on the back. And the South Sea is the Pacific, isn't it? The Pacific. And the story goes that James Cook is so taken with this, with the romance, the glamour, the excitement of it, that he takes this shilling from the till and replaces it with another shilling from his own pocket because he wants the very shiny South Sea shilling. But his master had spotted this
确实，他睡在柜台下面，因为他甚至没有房间。有一个非凡的故事，这些基础传说之一，一位女顾客在付钱买东西时。其中一枚硬币是一枚异常闪亮的先令，那是乔治一世统治时期铸造的南海先令，背面印有南海公司的印记。而南海就是太平洋，不是吗？太平洋。故事是说詹姆斯·库克被这个深深吸引，被它的浪漫、魅力、兴奋所吸引，以至于他从收银机里拿走了这枚先令，并用自己口袋里的另一枚先令代替了它，因为他想要那枚非常闪亮的南海先令。但他的主人发现了这枚
South Sea shilling and accuses James of having stolen it, which he hadn't. So some people, if they were being very caustic, Tom, and if they weren't going to Australia, would say, this is a foundational moment of Australian history, allegations of stealing followed by a swift exit towards the South Seas. But he probably didn't steal it, did he? Of course not. He's a figure of immense moral propriety. Yeah. But it foregrounds, obviously, the South Seas, the Pacific, where Cook will do his incredible voyages. But also, actually, the theme of stealing is a recurrent theme throughout his voyages.
南海先令，并指责詹姆斯偷了它，而他并没有。所以有些人，如果他们非常刻薄，汤姆，如果他们不去澳大利亚，会说，这是澳大利亚历史上的一个奠基时刻，偷窃指控随后是向南海的迅速撤离。但他可能没偷，对吧？当然没有。他是一个具有极高道德修养的人。是的。但这显然突出了南海，也就是太平洋，库克将在那里进行他不可思议的航行。但实际上，偷窃的主题也是他航行中反复出现的主题。
It's true, actually. It's a kind of flashpoint that keeps coming up. Yeah. And of course, critics of Cook now would say Cook himself is a symbol of theft and of colonial appropriation of other people's lands. I think perhaps unfairly. Well, we will discuss that, Tom. I mean, the thing is, because we are familiar with the world that he discovers, know the size of the pacific we can yeah you know look on a map and point out all the places and put arrows and things but i think you know to be stuck in a comfortable study
确实如此。这是一个不断出现的冲突点。是的。当然，库克现在的批评者会说库克本人是盗窃和殖民掠夺他人土地的象征。我认为这可能不公平。好吧，我们会讨论这个的，汤姆。我的意思是，问题在于，因为我们熟悉他发现的世界，知道太平洋的大小，我们可以，你知道，在地图上查看并指出所有的地方，画上箭头之类的，但我认为，你知道，被困在伦敦舒适的书房里
in london sneering at a man who goes out and braves his life yeah it ill behoves me to criticize him very good i approve of that tom slightly my feeling about So anyway, to go back to the shilling, Cook explains to his master, the apprentice master, the guy running the shop, what happened. And he says, listen, what do you want to do with your life, son? And young James Cook says, to go to sea, sir. Is that what he said? That's exactly what he said.
嘲笑一个走出去并冒着生命危险的人，这对我来说是不合适的。我批评他是不合适的。非常好，我赞同这一点，汤姆。稍微有点我的感觉。所以总之，回到先令的问题，库克向他的主人，那个学徒师傅，经营商店的人解释了发生了什么。他说，听着，你想用你的生命做什么，孩子？年轻的詹姆斯·库克说，去海上，先生。他是这么说的吗？他就是这么说的。
And the guy in the shop contacts a friend of his in Whitby, just down the coast or up the coast. Now, Whitby is a crucial port in the coal trade to London. So 1,000 ships a year would go down the eastern coast of England carrying a million tons of coal for this booming, industrializing capital city. And Cook joins them. So when Cook is 18, he's on his first voyage on what's called a cat, and that takes coal from Tyneside, from Newcastle
店里的人联系了他在惠特比的一个朋友，就在海岸下游或上游。现在，惠特比是煤炭贸易到伦敦的一个关键港口。所以每年有一千艘船沿着英格兰东海岸航行，为这个蓬勃发展、工业化的首都城市运送一百万吨煤炭。库克加入了他们。所以当库克 18 岁时，他第一次航行是在一艘所谓的“猫船”上，那艘船把煤炭从泰恩赛德，从纽卡斯尔
down to London. And it's there that he learns all the rudiments, doesn't he? Well, so I've got your notes in front of me. So by April 1750, he'd completed a three-year apprenticeship. And you tell me that he had learned the manual skills of close reefing a sail and holding a luff. Would you just, for the benefit of the listeners, Dominic, care to explain what holding a luff is i'd love to and that will be our next special bonus episode for our rest is history community the club members will be about holding a luff but i'm not going to waste it on the ordinary bunters but listeners should be reassured if they're worrying that after his apprenticeship
运往伦敦。就在那里他学会了所有的基本知识，不是吗？好吧，我有你的笔记在我面前。所以到 1750 年 4 月，他已经完成了三年的学徒期。你告诉我他学会了缩帆和保持帆缘的手工技能。多米尼克，为了听众的利益，你愿意解释一下什么是保持帆缘吗？我很乐意，那将是我们《历史余温》社区的下一个特别奖励剧集，俱乐部成员将了解关于保持帆缘的内容，但我不会把它浪费在普通的听众身上。但听众应该放心，如果他们担心学徒期后
cook couldn't hold a luff, he can. Well, he can use a hand spike when heaving on the windlass. He can do that. And he can take a running fix. He can read a barometer and predict the weather. But the key thing is that he can hold a luff. And this is what sets him up for a glittering future in maritime exploration. He actually is quite well-travelled, Tom. Seriously. He had gone to the Baltic. He'd gone to Kiel and Rostock, he would have gone to Konigsberg, to Malmo, maybe as far as Stockholm. These ships from the east coast of England, this was their kind of playground. And he's good at it. He's promoted to be a mate by 1752, so he's in his mid-twenties at this point. And then he's actually offered a ship of his own, a coal ship of his own, the Friendship in 1755 when he's 27. And the thing is, as we touched on in all the Nelson stuff, is that to be an experienced sailor, you need to be good at maths, don't you? Absolutely. Lots of stuff with compasses, working at angles.
库克不能保持帆缘，他可以。好吧，他在绞盘上用力时可以使用手柄。他可以做到。他可以进行航位推算。他可以读气压计并预测天气。但关键是他可以保持帆缘。这就是他未来在海上探索中取得辉煌成就的基础。他其实去过很多地方，汤姆。说真的。他去过波罗的海。他去过基尔和罗斯托克，他可能去过柯尼斯堡，去过马尔默，甚至可能远至斯德哥尔摩。这些来自英格兰东海岸的船只，这就是他们的游乐场。他很擅长。到 1752 年他被提升为大副，所以此时他二十多岁。然后他在 1755 年 27 岁时实际上被提供了一艘属于他自己的煤船，“友谊号”。问题是，正如我们在纳尔逊的所有事情中提到的那样，要成为一名经验丰富的水手，你需要擅长数学，不是吗？绝对是。有很多关于指南针、计算角度的事情。
All that shenanigans. Yeah, all that business. And he's very good at that. Absolutely. He's very good at it. So he's very good at holding aluf and he's very good at trigonometry and things. Exactly. Now, the interesting thing is he decides, so in the 1750s, the Seven Years' War, this titanic global confrontation between Great Britain and France, of course, with stuff going on in Europe as well, is fast approaching. And Cook seems to have decided that he would like to pursue a career in the Royal Navy. Why, we don't know. We don't have any insight into his inner life, but I'm guessing adventure, seeing the world. If that story about the South Sea shilling is true, I mean, he's not going to see the South
所有那些诡计。是的，所有那些事情。他非常擅长。绝对是。他非常擅长。所以他非常擅长保持帆缘，也非常擅长三角学之类的东西。完全正确。现在，有趣的是他决定，所以 1750 年代，七年战争，这场大不列颠和法国之间泰坦尼克式的全球对抗，当然，欧洲也发生了各种事情，正在迅速临近。库克似乎已经决定他想在皇家海军追求职业生涯。为什么，我们不知道。我们对他内心生活没有任何洞察，但我猜是冒险，看世界。如果关于南海先令的故事是真的，我的意思是，他看不到南海，不是吗？把煤运到伦敦之类的。不，绝对不是。但这可能，我的意思是，那个故事显然一定是伪造的。我一点也不相信，但它说明了，我想，一种对冒险的渴望。加入海军，看世界，一定是你必须有一种渴望。我的意思是，很多人都有。是的，所以 1755 年他去了伦敦沃平，他报名参加了，他志愿加入了皇家海军，并加入了“鹰号”军舰，由另一位叫休·帕利瑟的约克郡人担任船长。他们巡逻英吉利海峡的入口，不是吗？帕利瑟相当，我的意思是，他有点垃圾，不是吗？他是，但他看到了库克的才华。所以帕利瑟不是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，但帕利瑟给了库克关于导航和绘制海图的特别指导。
Seas, is he? Taking coal to London and stuff. No, absolutely not. But it might, I mean, clearly that story must be apocryphal. I don't believe it for a minute, but it speaks, I guess, of an appetite for adventure join the navy see the world must have been you must have had an appetite i mean so many people did yeah so in 1755 he goes down to whopping london he signs on he volunteers with the royal navy and he joins the ship hms eagle which is captained by another yorkshireman called hugh palliser they patrol the approaches to the English Channel, don't they? Palliser's quite, I mean, he's a bit rubbish, isn't he? He is, but he sees in Cook talent. So Palliser is not a terribly impressive person, but Palliser gives Cook special instructions in navigation and drawing up charts.
是的，因为库克是以海军水手的身份加入的，不是吗？他晋升得非常非常快。所以他晋升得很快。但他立即发现他有这个，你提到了他的三角学，他在绘制海军海图和测量事物方面有这种非凡的天赋。他绝对是天才。这对我们现在来说听起来非常无聊。如果你希望成为一个全球大国，并且你陷入了一场全球对抗，实际上知道你在哪里，土地上发生了什么，以及所有这些不同地方之间的关系，真的非常重要。嗯，当然，英法在北美竞争的焦点是加拿大，是的，魁北克，圣劳伦斯河。要让军队顺着
Yeah, because Cook has joined as a naval seaman, hasn't he? And he gets promoted very, very rapidly. So he's going up the ranks very fast. But he immediately discovers that he has this, you mentioned him in trigonometry, he has this extraordinary gift for drawing up naval charts and for surveying things. He's absolutely brilliant at it. And it sounds terribly boring to us now. If you are hoping to become a global power and you are locked in a global confrontation, actually knowing where you are and what's going on on the land and the relationship between all those different places really important well and also of course the great focus of anglo-french rivalry in north america is uh canada yeah and quebec the st lawrence river to get troops down
圣劳伦斯河而下，你需要知道所有的浅滩、海湾和一切，所以这绝对至关重要，绝对是整个战争的核心。确实如此。所以到 1757 年，库克是驶向魁北克的舰队的一部分。法国控制的魁北克，所以七年战争现在正如火如荼。库克是那个寻求从法国人手中夺取我们现在所称的加拿大控制权的队伍的一部分。他在这方面的关键部分是测量河流入口，所以他最终与一位陆军中尉汤姆组队，他以塞缪尔·霍兰德的名字为荣，这是一个伟大的名字，也许是我的一位祖先，谁知道呢，这家伙基本上是一名土地测量师，他会进行观察并做笔记，库克看着他做这些，完全被迷住了，心想，你知道吗，
the st lawrence river you need to know where all the shells are and the bays and everything so it's absolutely vital absolutely kind of central to the whole war. It is indeed. So by 1757, Cook is part of the fleet that sails up the St. Lawrence River towards Quebec. French held Quebec, so the Seven Years' War is now in full swing. And Cook is part of that party who is seeking to wrest control of what we would now call Canada from the French. And his key part in this is surveying the river approaches so he ends up to teaming up with an army lieutenant tom who rejoices in the name of samuel holland it's a great name maybe one of my ancestors who knows and this guy is a land surveyor basically he will take observations and he will make notes and cook sees him doing this and is completely transfixed by it thinks you know what
一件多么美妙的事情，我可以做这个。海岸，每一个礁石，每一个点，每一个海湾，每一块岩石。他们成了好朋友。库克在测量圣劳伦斯河方面发挥了关键作用。我要说关键作用。我的意思是，我们不要夸大其词。他绝不是这次征服的核心人物。他发挥了重要作用，一个重要的角色。
a wonderful thing i can do this of the coast, every reef, every point, every cove, every rock. And they become great friends. And Cook plays a key part in surveying the St. Lawrence River. I'm going to say key part. I mean, let's not overstate it. He's not the central figure in the conquest of this by any means. He plays an important part, a significant role.
他是配角的一部分。而且这相当艰苦，不是吗？因为 1758 年到 1759 年的那个冬天，我收集到的是有记录以来最冷的冬天，所以要在外面，你知道，用你的海图和东西扫描，我的意思是，那相当艰难。然后当竞选季节再次开始时，你知道，这很危险，因为他随时可能受到攻击。所以有一个事件，再次，在库克的青年时代非常迷人。有所有这些即将发生的事情的预兆。他带着他的海图和东西在外面。
He's part of the supporting cast. And it's quite grueling, isn't it? Because that winter of 1758 to 79 is 79 is i gather the coldest on record so to be out you know scanning with your charts and things i mean that's quite tough and then when the when the campaigning season starts again you know it's dangerous because he could be attacked at any time so there's one incident and again it's fascinating in Cook's youth. There are all these kind of prefigurings of what is to come. He's out there with his charts and things.
突然他遭到独木舟战士的攻击。所以独木舟将在即将到来的故事中发挥非常重要的作用。如果你喜欢独木舟的历史，这绝对是适合你的故事。我们有太多的独木舟。所以他们占领了魁北克。他后来留了下来。他绘制了哈利法克斯港的海图。他最终又回到了家，不是吗？他回到了伦敦东部的斯特普尼，
And suddenly he gets attacked by warriors in canoes. So canoes will play a very important part in the story that is to come. If you like the history of canoeing, this is absolutely the story for you. We've got so many canoes. So they capture Quebec. He stays on afterwards. He draws up the charts of Halifax Harbour. He eventually comes back home again, doesn't he? He comes back to Stepney, East London,
非常受欢迎的水手出没地。他找到了一个当地女孩叫伊丽莎白·巴茨，他们结婚了。非常好。他的测量天赋已经让他脱颖而出。现在英国已经，你知道，北美在英国手中，他们想测量它。
very popular kind of sailor's haunt. And he finds a local girl called Elizabeth Batts, and they get married. Very nice. His talent for surveying has already marked him out. Now that Britain has, you know, North America is in British hands, they want to survey it.
他们派他去绘制纽芬兰的整个海岸和拉布拉多的南海岸。你怎么发纽芬兰的音？我有点嘟囔，因为当这个词出现时，我想我们的加拿大听众给了我们某种关于纽芬兰的指示。我不记得是什么了。我不记得是什么了。纽芬兰，我想，加拿大听众给了我们某种关于纽芬兰的指示。我不记得是什么了。
And they send him out to chart the entire coast of Newfoundland and the southern coast of Labrador. How do you pronounce Newfoundland? I sort of mumbled that because as the word approached, I thought our Canadian listeners have given us some kind of instruction for Newfoundland. And I can't remember what it is. And I can't remember what it was. Newfoundland, I think, and Canadian listeners have given us some kind of instruction for Newfoundland. And I can't remember what it is.
我不记得是什么了。纽芬兰，我想是这样。是的。我想是“roo”。总之，他去了加拿大的那个部分。他花了四年时间。我的意思是，这是库克故事中非凡的事情之一。当你读他的传记时，它会说，在接下来的四年里，库克做了这件事。
And I can't remember what it was. Newfoundland, I think it is. Yeah. I think it's a roo. Anyway, off he goes to that part of Canada. And he spends four years. I mean, this is one of the extraordinary things about Cook's story. When you're reading his biography, it will say, for the next four years, Cook did it.
我知道。这是一个如此漫长的时期。你可以想象他在谈论它。然后第二天我出去了，我绘制了它。又一次。然后第二天，
I know. And it's such a long period of time. And you can imagine him talking about it. And then the next day I went out and I charted it. And again. And then next day,
我出去了，我绘制了它。事情就是这样继续下去的。所以是的，四年的热图行动。我想我们会跳过它。也许我们会把细节留给奖励剧集。绝对。
I went out and I charted it. And so it goes on. So yeah, so four years of hot chart action. Which we will skip, I think. Maybe we'll save the details of that for the bonus episode. Definitely.
连同他当时做的喘气和笑声之类的东西。当我们要宣布关于纽芬兰测量的六集系列节目时，人们肯定会知道《历史余温》的素材快用完了，到那时我们大概会知道怎么发这个名字的音了。所以是的，他做了这些。这些海图绝对令人惊叹。如果你喜欢航海海图，你就会知道它们有多棒。所以他又回到了家。它们非常成功，不是吗？所以海军部
Together with the huffing and laughing or whatever it is that he was doing as well. People will definitely know that the rest of his history is running out of material when we announce the six-part series on the surveying of Newfoundland, by which point presumably we'll know how to pronounce the name. So yes, he does this. These charts are absolutely amazing. If you like nautical charts, you will know how fantastic they are. So he comes back home again. And they're a great success, aren't they? So the Admiralty is
非常激动。他们称赞他“付出的努力和关注超出了我的描述”。是的。他已经确立了自己作为业内最好的地位。问题是，我认为为什么强调这一点很重要。所以你提到了埃尔南·科尔特斯。埃尔南·科尔特斯是一个贪婪、雄心勃勃的人，他想赚钱，他想在去墨西哥时进行冒险之类的，但他是个利己主义者。库克是一个更伟大事业的仆人，他是一个科学的人。他是一个学习和精确的人。但他也是一个工匠，不是吗？因为他从底层升上来。他做了所有保持帆缘之类的事情。
absolutely thrilled. They praise him for his pains and attention are beyond my description. Yes. He's established himself as the best in the business. And the thing is, and I think why it's important to emphasize this. So you mentioned Hernan Cortes. Hernan Cortes is a greedy, ambitious man who wants to make money and he wants to have adventures and stuff when he goes to Mexico, but he's self-interested. Cook is a servant for a greater cause and he is somebody who is a man of science. He's a man of learning and precision. But he's also a craftsman, isn't he? Because he's risen from the ranks. He's done all the holding lofts and stuff.
是的。但现在他是一个技术员，我想。技术员，完全正确。在他的整个职业生涯中，库克，他生命的意义似乎在于做一份工作并把它做得非常好。库克身上没有个人进步的感觉，特别是实际上个人的自我膨胀或野心，不是吗？他是团队的一部分。他喜欢成为老大并管理团队，
Yeah. But now he's a technician, I suppose. A technician, exactly. Throughout his career, Cook's, the meaning of his life seems to have resided in doing a job and doing it really, really well. There's no sense of individual advancement, particularly actually individual self-aggrandizement or ambition with Cook, is there? He's part of a team. He likes being the top dog and running the team,
但对他来说，工作总是最重要的。我不确定。我的意思是，正如听众会发现的那样，他确实有内心生活，但它非常非常私密。我认为他确实非常深刻地思考事情，他当然有情感的后方。但正如所有的约克郡人一样，多米尼克，我的意思是，你知道，我们了解约克郡人，不是吗？我们了解。他们喜欢把事情埋在心里。但对他来说，他是一个服务的人，不是吗？是的。
but it's always the job that matters to him. I'm not sure. I mean, as listeners will discover, he does have an inner life, but it's very, very kind of private. I think he does think about things very deeply and he certainly has emotional hinterlands. But as with all Yorkshiremen, Dominic, I mean, you know, we know Yorkshiremen, don't we? We do. They like to keep things close buried. But also with him, though, he's a man of the service, isn't he? Yeah.
同志情谊，海军的规则。是的。他绝对内化了所有这些东西。他是服务的产物。我的意思是，他是一种纪律的化身，我想，这使得皇家海军在 18 世纪如此有效。如果纳尔逊是那种魅力、虚张声势、冲劲和大胆的化身，库克则是关于方法论、工作、坚实的特征，我认为这就是为什么他的故事显然不如纳尔逊的故事华丽，说好吧，这就是为什么孩子们发现纳尔逊更
The camaraderie, the rules of the Navy. Yeah. He has absolutely internalised all that sort of stuff. He's a creature of the service. I mean, he's a kind of an embodiment of the discipline, I suppose, that makes the Royal Navy so effective in the 18th century. If Nelson is the embodiment of the kind of the glamour and the swagger and the dash and the daring, Cook is about the methodical, the workaday, the solid characteristics, which I think is why his story is obviously less flamboyant than Nelson's, saying well that's why children find nelson more
令人兴奋，因为我们被华丽、纳尔逊的明星品质所吸引，库克没有明星品质，在某种程度上，这就是为什么我怀疑人们相对容易取消他，因为他没有热情的拥护者，因为他不像纳尔逊那样有某种直接的、发自内心的吸引力和魅力。我知道我们并没有完全推销这个，但我认为我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看库克职业生涯的伟大转折点，当他被任命为前往南海的探险队时。而且，陪同他参加这次旅行的人，甚至动物，使这一切变得非常非常戏剧化。
exciting because we're drawn to the flamboyant the star quality of nelson cook doesn't have star quality and that's in a way why it's been i suspect it's been relatively easy for people to cancel him because he doesn't have passionate advocates because there's not something immediately viscerally appealing and charismatic about him as there is with Nelson. And I'm aware that we're not entirely selling this, but I think we should take a break now. And when we come back, we will look at the great turning point in Cook's career when he gets appointed to an expedition to the South Seas. But also the people and indeed the animals who accompany him on this trip makes it all very, very dramatic.
所以我们休息后见。Chiara，在意大利语中意味着聪明。可惜你的咖啡师拼不对。所以你只能报个假名，你的咖啡馆名字，Giulia。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己像是在接受证人保护。等等。Giulia 到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？
So we will see you back after the break. Chiara, it means smart in Italian. Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Giulia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order?
但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了。因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余温》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，
But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this. Because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余温》。我们正在谈论库克船长，多米尼克。更具体地说，我们现在要做我知道是你的一大热情所在，那就是天文学，不是吗？所以库克回到了伦敦。他作为一名擅长海图的稳重男人，拥有了辉煌的声誉。恰好因为一个令人兴奋的天文现象，需要这样一个人。你愿意告诉听众这个令人兴奋的天文现象是什么吗？汤姆，我绝对愿意。正如听众所知，18 世纪是一个
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking Captain Cook and Dominic. More specifically, we're now going to do what I know is a great passion of yours, which is astronomy, isn't it? So Cook has come back to London. He's got this splendid reputation as a solid man who's good with a chart. And it so happens that just such a man is needed because of an exciting astronomical occurrence. Would you like to tell the listeners what this exciting astronomical occurrence is? Tom, I absolutely would. As the listeners will know, the 18th century is a high point
在测绘、分类和归类事物方面的高峰。人们想要测绘、分类和归类的事物之一是太阳系。而其中的一个关键要素，汤姆，是计算出事物之间的距离。当然。伟大的天文学家，埃米特·哈雷。就像彗星一样。就像彗星一样。哈雷彗星，就像 1066 年一样。
in mapping and categorizing and classifying things. One of the things people want to map and categorize and classify is the solar system. And a key element of that, Tom, is to work out how far apart things are. Of course. And the great astronomer, Emmett Halley. As in the comet. As in the comet. Halley's comet, as in 1066.
正确。我想说，汤姆，我只是在想表达它的最好方式。也许最好的表达方式是让我说，他已经计算出，稀有且间隔不均匀的行星金星的凌日，当然它是离地球最近的，金星穿过太阳表面的凌日将提供，通过相对简单的计算，你将能够……是的，继续。金星将穿过
Correct. He had, I think it's fair to say, Tom, I'm just trying to think of the best way of putting it. Maybe the best way of putting it is for me to say that he had worked out that the rare and unevenly spaced transits of the planet Venus, which of course is the closest to the Earth, that the transits of Venus across the face of the sun would offer, through relatively simple calculations, you would be able to... Yeah, go on.us is going to move across
太阳，汤姆，我不知道你为什么觉得这这么好笑，因为实际上我非常珍惜在《历史余温》中谈论科学的机会，这实际上是一件相当严肃的事情。是的，金星凌日，它将穿过太阳，嗯，如果你能从地球上的不同点观察它，你将会有各种各样的好处。为什么？嗯，你将知道金星和其他行星以及太阳和水星之间的距离。无论什么东西。
the sun tom i don't know why you find this so funny because actually i relish the opportunity to talk about science and the rest is history it's actually quite a serious business yeah the transit of venus across the sun it's going to move across the sun and um if you can observe it from different points on the earth you you'll have all kinds of benefits. Why? Well, you'll know the distances between Venus and other planets and the sun and Mercury. Whatever stuff.
无论什么东西让你感兴趣，你都会知道这一切。对。皇家学会写了一封信给国王。他们说，听着，金星不经常穿过太阳。因为它直到 1874 年才会再次发生。正确。它在 1761 年做过，但我们把它搞得一团糟。这是在七年战争期间，我想，不是吗？
Whatever stuff interests you, you'll know all this. Right. And the Royal Society writes a letter to the king. They say, listen, Venus doesn't move across the sun very often. Because it's not going to happen again until 1874. Correct. It did it in 1761, but we made a massive horlicks of it. This was during the Seven Years' War, I think, wasn't it?
是的。伟大的强国说，让我们做吧，尽管有战争，但他们把它搞砸了。所以他们说，1769 年是我们能做到的那一年。他们对乔治说，听着，欧洲的几个大国，特别是法国人、西班牙人、丹麦人和瑞典人，正在为观察它做适当的安排。他们说，英国民族长期以来以热爱天文学而闻名，在这方面我们不逊色于地球上任何古代或现代的民族。
Yeah. And the great powers had said, let's do it, despite the war, and they'd made a mess of it. So they said, 1769 is the one year we can do it. They said to George, listen, several of the great powers in Europe, particularly the French, Spaniards, Danes, and Swedes, are making the proper dispositions for the observation thereof. The British nation, they say, has been long renowned for its love of astronomy, in which we are inferior to no nation on Earth, ancient or modern.
是的。尽管战争还在继续，大国们还是决定要进行观测，结果却搞得一团糟。于是他们说，1769年是我们唯一能进行观测的机会。他们对乔治说，听着，欧洲的几个大国，特别是法国、西班牙、丹麦和瑞典，都在为观测金星凌日做准备。他们说，英国向来以热爱天文学而闻名，在这方面，无论是古代还是现代，我们都不逊色于地球上的任何国家。
It would be very dishonorable if we didn't also observe the transit of Venus. I think these are admirable reasons for doing it, isn't it? Excellent reasons. The love of science and putting down the French. So basically what they need to do, the Royal Navy needs to send a ship out. The best place to see it is from the South Pacific. All right, let's crack on. Let's go over there, observe the transit of Venus. We need a ship and we need somebody who's good at trigonometry. And that man is Captain James Cook. And they pick him and they pick the ship which is
如果我们不去观测金星凌日，那将是非常不光彩的。我认为这些是进行观测的合理理由，不是吗？非常好的理由。对科学的热爱，以及压制法国人。所以基本上他们需要做的是，皇家海军需要派出一艘船。观测它的最佳地点是南太平洋。好了，让我们开始吧。让我们去那里，观测金星凌日。我们需要一艘船，还需要一个精通三角学的人。那个人就是詹姆斯·库克船长。他们选中了他，也选中了那艘船，也就是
of course the endeavor tom it is the endeavor so endeavor will be well known to anyone who's ever watched inspector morse it's his first name yeah and the name i gather that um cook had nothing to do with the choice of the name it's just kind of one of those random things yes and um nicholas thomas in his wonderful book points out that the ship could just as easily have been called the racehorse or even the carcass which was the name given to to other vessels that were sent out on scientific expeditions the following year so captain cook's voyages on the carcass wouldn't have had at all the yeah the heft or resonance yeah the racehorse would be quite fun. But Endeavour obviously is
当然是“奋进号”，汤姆，确实是“奋进号”。所以“奋进号”对于任何看过《摩斯探长》的人来说都很熟悉，那是他的名字。是的，据我所知，库克对这个名字的选择没什么发言权，这只是那种随机的事情之一。是的，尼古拉斯·托马斯在他那本精彩的书中指出，这艘船完全可以被命名为“赛马号”，甚至是“尸骸号”，这是第二年被派往科学考察的其他船只的名字。所以库克船长在“尸骸号”上的航行将完全没有那种分量或共鸣。是的，“赛马号”会很有趣。但“奋进号”显然是
perfect. I mean, it's expressive of everything that not just the expedition, but Cook personally embodies. I mean, Endeavour is what he is about. So it's a solid ship. It's not big by any means. And it has guns, but it's not a fighting ship. It's not a warship, is it? It's not a warship. No. So Cook has, mean he's he's been in one battle i think hasn't he yeah he's been under fire he's commanded by admiral bing who ended up being shot on the deck to encourage yeah yeah yeah but he's he's not really a fighting man he's going out there to survey and they decide that you know if they're going to tahiti then obviously they've got to get to the pacific they do exactly so tahiti is the place they're going to make for to build this um
完美的。我的意思是，它表达了不仅是这次探险，而且是库克个人所体现的一切。我的意思是，“奋进号”就是他所代表的。所以这是一艘坚固的船。它绝不算大。它有火炮，但它不是一艘战斗舰。它不是军舰，对吧？它不是军舰。不。所以库克，我的意思是，他只参加过一次战斗，我想，对吧？是的，他曾身处炮火之下，他在宾海军上将的指挥下，宾海军上将最终在甲板上被枪决以鼓舞士气。是的，是的，但他并不是一个真正的战斗人员。他去那里是为了测量，他们决定，你知道，如果他们要去塔希提岛，那么显然他们必须到达太平洋。他们确实是这样做的。所以塔希提岛是他们要去建立这个……
astronomical station so they can see venus doing whatever it the place they're going to make for to build this astronomical station so they can see Venus doing whatever it's doing. They're going to go off to the Pacific, just on the Pacific. It's not totally unknown, is it? Because, of course, Balboa saw it in Panama. So we're talking about this in the Cortez episode. Exactly. In the 16th century, Magellan had sailed into it. Drake had been across it?
天文台的地方，这样他们就能看到金星在做任何它正在做的事情。他们要去太平洋，就在太平洋上。它并非完全不为人知，对吧？因为，当然，巴尔博亚在巴拿马看到了它。所以我们在科尔特斯那一集中谈到了这一点。没错。在16世纪，麦哲伦曾航行进入其中。德雷克曾横穿过它？
Yeah. Francis Drake? People had sort of nibbled away across it yeah francis drake people had sort of nibbled away at the edges hadn't they particularly spanish mariners and then later on the dutch but the key thing is is that there are vast expanses of it people have no idea what is there and there is a kind of theoretical argument that is seriously advanced that if there is eurasia and africa in the northern hemisphere there Eurasia and Africa in the Northern Hemisphere, there must be a balancing continent in the Southern Hemisphere. The British Admiralty are not
是的。弗朗西斯·德雷克？人们已经在某种程度上蚕食了它。是的，弗朗西斯·德雷克，人们已经在某种程度上蚕食了它的边缘，不是吗？特别是西班牙水手，后来是荷兰人。但关键在于，它有广阔的区域，人们根本不知道那里有什么。而且有一种理论论点被认真地提出来，即如果北半球有欧亚大陆和非洲，那么在南半球一定有一个平衡的大陆。英国海军部并没有
publicly saying this. It's all about science, it's all about astronomy and the transit of Venus and so on. But secretly, they're thinking, we can combine the trip to Tahiti to track Venus with a kind of land grab of this huge continent, if we can only find it. That's right. So the name that people give to this, they talk about the existence of the great southern continent, or Terra Australis. Named actually, supposedly, because there was a letter to the King of Spain, whose dynastic name was Austria. And Portuguese navigators said, when we do discover this land, we will call it Australia after your majesty. And the thing is, as you say, Tom, first of all, they think, I mean, it's an age when people are fascinated by the idea of symmetry and balance,
公开说这一点。这完全是关于科学，关于天文学和金星凌日等等。但私下里，他们认为，我们可以将前往塔希提岛观测金星的行程与对这片巨大大陆的某种土地掠夺结合起来，如果我们能找到它的话。没错。所以人们给这个地方起的名字，他们谈论的是南方大陆或“南方大陆”的存在。实际上，据说是以西班牙国王的名字命名的，他的王朝名字是奥地利。葡萄牙航海家说，当我们发现这片土地时，我们将以陛下的名字称它为澳大利亚。问题是，正如你所说，汤姆，首先，他们认为，我的意思是，这是一个人们对对称和平衡的概念着迷的时代，
isn't it? Because it's the scientific revolution, because people are drawing up maps and they appear to see the Americas being a sort of mirror image of Europe and Africa. And they become convinced, as you say, that there's something out there. Now, at the same time, Dutchmen like Tasman, Abel Tasman in the 1640s, he had sailed around Australia and New Zealand. He didn't really understand the relationship between Australia and New Zealand. People know there was something there. What they don't know- Is how large it is. How large it is. And they don't know whether Australia and New Zealand, people know there is something there. What they don't know- Is how large it is. How large it is. And they don't know whether Australia and New Zealand,
不是吗？因为这是科学革命，因为人们正在绘制地图，他们似乎看到美洲是欧洲和非洲的某种镜像。正如你所说，他们变得确信那里有什么东西。现在，与此同时，像塔斯曼这样的荷兰人，阿贝尔·塔斯曼在1640年代，他曾航行环绕澳大利亚和新西兰。他并没有真正理解澳大利亚和新西兰之间的关系。人们知道那里有东西。他们不知道的是——它有多大。它有多大。而且他们不知道澳大利亚和新西兰，
this land that they've vaguely glimpsed, are these islands? Or is this part of this great southern continent? Or is Terra Australis something else between Australia and New Zealand and Antarctica? So all of this is unknown. And it's a particular focus of British interest. So there are two kind of key figures that are fostering the sense that there might be something out there to discover. And one of them is a ship's captain called Samuel Wallace, who is from Cornwall and who in 1767 had set off in a ship called the Dolphin. And he had kind of ventured into the pacific regions where perhaps this
这片他们模糊瞥见的土地，是岛屿吗？还是这片南方大陆的一部分？或者“南方大陆”是澳大利亚、新西兰和南极洲之间的其他东西？所以这一切都是未知的。这是英国利益的一个特别焦点。所以有两种关键人物在培养这种可能存在某种东西等待发现的感觉。其中之一是一位名叫塞缪尔·沃利斯的船长，他来自康沃尔，1767年他乘坐一艘名为“海豚号”的船出发了。他曾冒险进入太平洋地区，也许这个
continent might be lurking and claims to have kind of what is it seen in the distance peaks top by clouds and yeah and um he sees the peaks through the fog but then the fog closed in and the site was lost he landed on an island vaguely nearby where he said um the verdure is as fine as that of england there is great plenty of livestock and it abounds all the choices productions of the earth and he called it king george's land of course we would know it as tahiti so he's in that kind of neck of the woods he's seen something vaguely near tahiti but he doesn't know what it is and he returned from that voyage just before Cook left in the endeavor. So it's possible that Cook would have met him and talked to him.
大陆可能潜伏在那里，并声称在远处看到了云层覆盖的山峰。是的，他在雾中看到了山峰，但随后雾气合拢，景象消失了。他在附近的一个岛屿上登陆，他说那里的植被和英国的一样好，有大量的牲畜，而且物产丰富，他称之为乔治国王领地。当然，我们称之为塔希提岛。所以他就在那个地区，他在塔希提岛附近模糊地看到了一些东西，但他不知道那是什么。他在库克乘坐“奋进号”离开之前刚刚从那次航行中返回。所以库克有可能见过他并与他交谈过。
Oh, I think more than possible. I think he does for a reason that we'll come to in due course, because Samuel Wallace gives Cook something wonderful and crucial, which we will come to. Oh, I don't know what that is. I can't wait to find out. And what's the other person you're going to talk about another person. So Willie Dalrymple, star of our sister show Empire, he has hundreds of ancestors, basically endlessly teeming all over the British Empire. And this ancestor is a guy called Alexander,
哦，我认为不仅仅是有可能。我认为他确实见过，原因我们稍后会讲到，因为塞缪尔·沃利斯给了库克一些美妙而关键的东西，我们稍后会讲到。哦，我不知道那是什么。我迫不及待想知道了。你要谈论的另一个人是谁？另一个人。所以威利·达尔林普尔，我们姐妹节目《帝国》的明星，他有数百位祖先，基本上在大英帝国各地繁衍生息。而这位祖先是一个叫亚历山大的人，
who is a geographer. And he is the guy who is really pushing this idea that there's a huge continent waiting to be found. And he hasn't himself been there, but he has read all the available sources from previous voyages. So Drake's, but also the Spanish, Portuguese, Dutch ventures there and kind of synthesizing them. And he's very desperate to go and lead the endeavor. He's very, very hopeful of it. And so when Cook gets appointed instead, he's a bit upset about that. But he doesn't go off in a complete huff. He's
他是一位地理学家。他就是那个真正推动“有一个巨大的大陆等待被发现”这一想法的人。他自己并没有去过那里，但他阅读了之前航行的所有可用资料。所以德雷克的，还有西班牙、葡萄牙、荷兰在那里的冒险，并对它们进行了综合。他非常渴望去领导“奋进号”。他对此非常、非常抱有希望。所以当库克被任命时，他对此感到有点难过。但他并没有完全生气。他
still contributing papers and ideas and proposals to the expedition. So he's another guy who is pushing this idea. So this is the secret mission. After watching the transit of Venus, Cook is basically going to be told to go down and have an explore in the southernmost reaches of the Pacific. But there is a further dimension to the voyage, which is that it is committed to the idea of knowledge for knowledge's sake. Because if you are going to lands that are unknown, there will presumably be all kinds of rare plants and animals. And if these rare plants and animals are going to be gathered, you need someone who is qualified to collect them.
仍然在为探险提供论文、想法和建议。所以他是另一个推动这个想法的人。所以这就是秘密任务。在观看金星凌日后，库克基本上会被告知去探索太平洋的最南端。但这次航行还有一个更深层的维度，那就是它致力于“为知识而知识”的理念。因为如果你要去未知的土地，那里大概会有各种稀有的动植物。如果这些稀有的动植物要被收集，你需要一个有资格收集它们的人。
And it's at this point that an absolutely tremendous character pops up and enters the story. And this is a man called Joseph Banks. So Tom, if you, I mean, I know you are now in love with the books by Patrick O'Brien. So Joseph Banks is clearly an inspiration for the character of Stephen Maturin, isn't he? And the relationship between Aubrey and Maturin is Coggan-Banks. Patrick O'Brien wrote a biography of Banks. Yes.
就在这时，一个绝对了不起的人物出现了，进入了故事。这个人叫约瑟夫·班克斯。所以汤姆，如果你，我的意思是，我知道你现在很喜欢帕特里克·奥布莱恩的书。所以约瑟夫·班克斯显然是斯蒂芬·马图林这个角色的灵感来源，不是吗？奥布里和马图林之间的关系就是库克和班克斯。帕特里克·奥布莱恩写过一本班克斯的传记。是的。
But Maturin is quite a sober, serious character. Banks, I think it's fair to say, is not. Banks is what Charles Darwin would have been if he'd been a massive lad. Yeah. So he's very, very wealthy, probably one of the 200 wealthiest families in the country, from Lincolnshire gentry, went to Harrow, then went to Eton. Went to both Eton and Harrow. At Eton, he shot a swan and baked it in a pie.
但马图林是一个相当清醒、严肃的角色。我认为可以公平地说，班克斯不是。班克斯就是如果查尔斯·达尔文是一个超级大男孩会是什么样子。是的。所以他非常、非常富有，可能是全国200个最富有的家庭之一，来自林肯郡的乡绅，上过哈罗公学，然后去了伊顿公学。既上过伊顿公学也上过哈罗公学。在伊顿公学，他射杀了一只天鹅并把它烤成了馅饼。
So that's very much the kind of the measure of the kind of guy he is. That's the kind of botany he enjoys. Absolutely. So he inherits his father's fortune. And the expectation is, of course, if you're a wealthy young man, he's been to Eton, he goes on to Christchurch at Oxford, where rather than studying classics, he studies botany, which is very unusual. I think the guy who teaches botany at Oxford is generally reckoned to have been the worst teacher in the entire history of Oxford University. Right, and that is saying something, Tom.
所以这在很大程度上衡量了他是一个什么样的人。这就是他喜欢的植物学。绝对是。所以他继承了他父亲的财产。当然，期望是，如果你是一个富有的年轻人，他上过伊顿公学，他会去牛津大学的基督教会学院，在那里他没有学习古典文学，而是学习植物学，这非常不寻常。我认为在牛津大学教植物学的那个人通常被认为是牛津大学历史上最糟糕的老师。对，这说明了问题，汤姆。
He had one lecture that he just gave over and over again every week for 30 years. But this didn't put Banks off at all. And so rather than go on the Grand Tour, he scorns that. He says that every blockhead does that. My Grand Tour shall be won round the whole globe. And so his ambition is to go off and see the world. So his first venture, actually like Captain Cook, he goes off to Newfoundland. But rather than going around looking at bays and doing charts, he is there to spot birds and things. So
他有一门课，在30年里每周都重复讲。但这并没有让班克斯退缩。所以他没有去进行大巡游，他对此嗤之以鼻。他说每个笨蛋都会那样做。我的大巡游将是环绕整个地球。所以他的抱负是去看看世界。所以他的第一次冒险，实际上像库克船长一样，他去了纽芬兰。但与其到处看海湾和绘制图表，他在那里是为了观察鸟类和事物。所以
in the course of his scientific trip to Newfoundland, he sees penguins, he sees large species of other bird, and he sees the scalp of a fisherman who'd been killed by an Eskimo, as he calls it. So an Inuit. Crikey. That's exciting. And also, and this is very Banks, he learns to play the guitar. If you think of somebody doing a gap year being really annoying. Yeah.
在他去纽芬兰的科学考察过程中，他看到了企鹅，看到了其他大型鸟类，还看到了一个被爱斯基摩人（正如他所称）杀死的渔夫的头皮。所以是因纽特人。天哪。那太令人兴奋了。而且，这非常班克斯，他学会了弹吉他。如果你想到有人在间隔年里表现得非常烦人。是的。
You went to the gap year, didn't you, Tom? I did. I went to India. You went to India? Yeah. I did the classic. Que le surprise. Yeah, you did.
你参加过间隔年，对吧，汤姆？我参加过。我去了印度。你去了印度？是的。我做了经典的那个。真令人惊讶。是的，你做了。
So I very much identify with Joseph Banks. I thought you would. I think he's a tremendous chap. I am the cook and you are the banks in this podcast. I think it's fair to say. Yes, I think that's probably true. Anyway, so he picks up on the fact that the Endeavour is going off on this trip and he thinks, this is my chance. I can absolutely do this. And by great good fortune, he was at school with the first Lord of the Admiralty. The Earl of Sandwich, right? The Earl of Sandwich.
所以我非常认同约瑟夫·班克斯。我以为你会的。我认为他是一个了不起的家伙。在这个播客里，我是库克，你是班克斯。我认为可以公平地说。是的，我想这可能是真的。总之，他得知“奋进号”要进行这次旅行，他想，这是我的机会。我绝对可以做到。而且非常幸运的是，他和第一海军大臣是校友。三明治伯爵，对吧？三明治伯爵。
He can't have been at school with him, actually. But anyway, he knows him. Yeah. And so he pulls strings and he gets a berth, which is quite bad news for Cook because the cabin is very, very small. I mean, tiny. Oh, the boat. It's stuffed with guns, food, astronomical stuff.
他不可能和他一起上学，实际上。但无论如何，他认识他。是的。所以他动用关系，获得了一个铺位，这对库克来说是个坏消息，因为船舱非常、非常小。我的意思是，很小。哦，那艘船。它塞满了枪支、食物、天文设备。
He's also got to take astronomers to do all the calculations that we so beautifully described. And now he discovers he's got to take this posh botanist. Plus, Banks has got all these cronies and hangers on, hasn't he? Well, they're not cronies. I think you could call them assistants, scientific assistants. So this is really the first ever scientific research team. The idea that you go off on an expedition and you don't just have one kind of gentleman, you have a whole crew. So painters who can record things and all kinds of stuff and all kinds of kit. So very extravag think the whole kind of fitting out of the Endeavour and the expedition only costs £3,000. So basically, it's probably closer to £6,000. But Banks' luggage is worth more than twice the Endeavour itself. Wow.
他还得带上天文学家来做我们描述得那么美妙的所有计算。现在他发现他还得带上这个时髦的植物学家。另外，班克斯还有一堆亲信和随从，不是吗？嗯，他们不是亲信。我想你可以称他们为助手，科学助手。所以这确实是第一个科学研究团队。你进行探险，不仅仅带一个绅士，而是带一整队人的想法。所以有可以记录事物的画家，还有各种各样的东西和各种各样的装备。所以非常奢侈。我认为“奋进号”和探险队的整个装备费用只有3000英镑。所以基本上，可能更接近6000英镑。但班克斯的行李价值是“奋进号”本身的两倍多。哇。
I mean, he's got... So on the assistance, there's a guy, there's a Swedish bloke called Dr. Solander, who was a pupil of Linnaeus. Possibly a spy, a Swedish spy. Yes. There's also a bloke who's there just to paint all the flowers, isn't there? Sidney Parkinson. Yeah. He's a Quaker.
我的意思是，他有……关于助手，有一个人，有一个叫索兰德博士的瑞典人，他是林奈的学生。可能是一个间谍，一个瑞典间谍。是的。还有一个家伙在那里只是为了画所有的花，不是吗？西德尼·帕金森。是的。他是一个贵格会教徒。
He's not a massive barrel of laughs, I think it's fair to say. So there's this huge team. But also, Cook has to fit in this huge crew, about 100 people, I think, in the crew. And they're a real, you know, as Dr. Salander would call them, no doubt, they're a smorgasbord of people, Tom. They are. And not only that, but there are animals. So I mentioned that the likelihood that Cook had met Captain Wallace, who was in charge of the dolphin. And we know this because
我想可以公平地说，他不是一个特别有趣的人。所以有这么大的团队。但库克也必须容纳这庞大的船员，我想船员大约有100人。他们真的是，你知道，正如索兰德博士会称呼他们的那样，毫无疑问，他们是一群大杂烩，汤姆。他们确实是。不仅如此，还有动物。所以我提到了库克可能见过负责“海豚号”的沃利斯船长。我们知道这一点，因为
Captain Wallace had taken a she-goat that supplied milk the whole way around the course of the three-year voyage and had been right the way around the world. And he suggests that Cook take this goat. Same goat. Yeah. And Cook is absolutely delighted. She was three years in the West Indies and was once around the world before in the dolphin and never went dry the whole time. So Cook thinks, this is brilliant. I can have milk with my tea. Fantastic. So the goat is put on there is also a cat to catch rats yes and banks of course takes two dogs a greyhound and greyhounds so greyhound on a ship i mean they're great in a
沃利斯船长带了一只母山羊，在三年的航行中全程提供牛奶，并且已经环游了世界。他建议库克带上这只山羊。同一只山羊。是的。库克非常高兴。她在西印度群岛待了三年，之前在“海豚号”上环游过世界，而且一直没有断奶。所以库克想，这太棒了。我喝茶时可以加牛奶。太棒了。所以山羊被放了上去，还有一只猫来抓老鼠。是的，班克斯当然带了两条狗，一条灵缇犬和灵缇犬。所以船上有灵缇犬，我的意思是，它们在
closed space um and another dog called lady oh that's nice so you know i love dogs on ships yeah yeah so it's a packed vessel yes and by the, the sailors are from all over the place. I mean, they're not just British, are they? They're from Corcan Island. There's a Brazilian. There's a Venetian. There's some New Yorkers. Yeah. It's a real mixture.
封闭空间里很棒，还有另一条叫“女士”的狗。哦，那很好。所以你知道，我喜欢船上的狗。是的，是的。所以这是一艘拥挤的船。是的，而且水手们来自各地。我的意思是，他们不仅仅是英国人，对吧？他们来自科西嘉岛。有一个巴西人。有一个威尼斯人。还有一些纽约人。是的，这真的是一个混合体。
Yeah. So lots of fun. And they get ready to go. And Cook takes leave of his wife, Elizabeth, who is pregnant and the three children. So it's goodbye, wife. Goodbye, children. Is that what he said? I'll be seeing thee.
是的。所以很有趣。他们准备出发了。库克告别了他的妻子伊丽莎白，她当时怀孕了，还有三个孩子。所以是再见，妻子。再见，孩子们。他是这么说的吗？我会见到你的。
And off he goes. Meanwhile, Banks, and I quote here from Toby Musgrave, who's written a very entertaining biography of Banks, The Multifarious Mr. Banks. In the midst of his exhilaration and hasty departure, Banks had behaved like a cad towards a certain Miss Harriet Blossett.
然后他就出发了。与此同时，班克斯，我在这里引用托比·马斯格雷夫的话，他写了一本关于班克斯的非常有趣的传记，《多才多艺的班克斯先生》。在兴奋和匆忙离开的过程中，班克斯对一位哈丽特·布洛塞特小姐表现得像个无赖。
So his guitar, his dogs, it's very expensive luggage, and now he's behaved like a cad. So it's a tremendous send off. But actually, Cook and Banks get on very well. Maybe because they're so different. Maybe because they're not competing. Yeah. Banks is much younger, of course. I mean, he's about 13 years younger, I think. Yeah. But I think he's fun. Yes. I think he's a kind of enjoyable companion. The cook is not fun, Tom. That's fair to say. Cook is serious. No, but I think perhaps that funster that Banks is, maybe he coaxes cook out of his shell or
所以他的吉他，他的狗，非常昂贵的行李，现在他又表现得像个无赖。所以这是一个了不起的送行。但实际上，库克和班克斯相处得很好。也许是因为他们太不同了。也许是因为他们没有竞争。是的。班克斯当然年轻得多。我的意思是，我想他年轻了大约13岁。是的。但我认为他很有趣。是的。我认为他是一个令人愉快的同伴。库克并不有趣，汤姆。这很公平。库克很严肃。不，但我认为也许班克斯那个有趣的人，也许他诱导库克走出了他的壳，或者
something. Possibly. Have you seen what they took on board? Four tonnes of beer, 185 pounds of Devonshire cheese, tonnes of meat and salt beef. But the thing that Cook particularly believes in that he's always forcing people to eat is sauerkraut, obsessed with sauerkraut. Because this is to keep scurvy at bay, isn't it? So this is also part of what he's trying to do is research whether it's possible to stop scurvy from happening. So people are just being forced to eat sauerkraut morning, noon, and night, because Cook believes, quite rightly, that a healthy diet is crucial. He's not wrong. He's not the first person to think of this, but there is an argument
什么的。可能。你看到他们带了什么上船了吗？四吨啤酒，185磅德文郡奶酪，吨计的肉和咸牛肉。但库克特别相信的一件事，他总是强迫人们吃的是酸菜，对酸菜着迷。因为这是为了防止坏血病，不是吗？所以这也是他试图做的事情的一部分，即研究是否有可能阻止坏血病的发生。所以人们只是被迫在早、中、晚吃酸菜，因为库克相信，非常正确地，健康的饮食是至关重要的。他没有错。他不是第一个想到这一点的人，但有一种论点
that he is the great populariser of the kind of anti-scurvy. Well, and again, people who've listened to our episodes on Trafalgar will remember that we said that a Royal Navy ship is probably the healthiest place in the world, counterintuitively, because the research into public health is so intense there. Because obviously, disease or scurvy or whatever can wipe an expedition out. And cook plays a key role in ensuring that by the time you get to Nelson's generation, these ships are unbelievably healthy. Dominic, just on the topic of of food matter that is taken banks packs a very delicious cheshire cheese uh and a cask of porter and i want listeners to bear that in mind because it will reappear later in the exciting he's taken it for
认为他是抗坏血病方法的伟大推广者。嗯，同样，听过我们关于特拉法加战役剧集的人会记得，我们说过皇家海军的船只可能是世界上最健康的地方，这与直觉相反，因为对公共卫生的研究在那里非常深入。因为显然，疾病或坏血病或任何东西都可能摧毁一次探险。库克在确保到纳尔逊那一代时，这些船只变得极其健康方面发挥了关键作用。多米尼克，就在食物的话题上，班克斯带了非常美味的柴郡奶酪和一桶波特啤酒，我希望听众记住这一点，因为它稍后会出现在令人兴奋的……他带它是为了
a specific reason okay that i will not yet reveal anyway they set sail at two o'clock on the 26th of august 1768 pull out to sea and inevitably banks starts hurling everywhere he's violently violently ceasing yeah he is but he must have recovered a little bit because by the time they get to madeira which is the sort of classic stop that you make banks is well enough to go ashore and interfere with plants yes and do whatever he is doing yes and he's doing that thing that maturin is always doing where he's kind of laying nets out and scooping up kind of insects and stuff like that sea creatures and things they cross the equator don't they on the 26th october this is an occasion for much jollity much nautical jollity because anyone who crosses the equator for the first time has to get dunked in the sea or pay a fine in alcohol on a kind of
一个特定的原因，好的，我暂时不会透露。总之，他们在1768年8月26日两点起航，驶向大海，不可避免地，班克斯开始到处呕吐。他剧烈地、剧烈地晕船。是的，他是，但他一定恢复了一点，因为当他们到达马德拉群岛时，那是你通常会做的经典停靠，班克斯身体状况好到可以上岸干扰植物，是的，做他正在做的任何事情。是的，他正在做马图林总是做的那种事情，他会铺开网，捞起昆虫之类的东西，海洋生物等等。他们穿过赤道，不是吗？在10月26日，这是一个充满欢乐的场合，充满航海的欢乐，因为任何第一次穿过赤道的人都必须被浸入海中或支付酒精罚款。在一种
frame there's like a frame isn't there and they're dunked in the sea or pay a fine in alcohol. On a kind of frame. There's like a frame, isn't there? And they're dunked in the sea on the end of a rope. Yeah. Three times deep into the sea, which kind of could be quite fun or quite frightening. I would have thought. Of course, a lot of these people can't swim, can they? I mean, it's one of the great things about Royal Navy.
框架上，有一个框架，不是吗？他们被浸入海中或支付酒精罚款。在一种框架上。有一个框架，不是吗？他们被绳子吊着浸入海中。是的。三次深入海中，这可能很有趣，也可能很可怕。我本来会这么想的。当然，这些人中有很多不会游泳，对吧？我的意思是，这是皇家海军的伟大之处之一。
Yeah. A lot of them are frightened of swimming. This comes up again and again in Patrick O'Brien's novels. Banks refuses to do this. so he has to forfeit. Well, so does Cook, because Cook hasn't been over the equator. Yeah, but it would look terrible for Cook as the captain to be dunked by his... I would, I mean, I'd pay a fine in that situation, I think. Oh, I'd do the dunking.
是的。他们很多人害怕游泳。这在帕特里克·奥布莱恩的小说中反复出现。班克斯拒绝这样做。所以他必须没收。嗯，库克也是，因为库克没有越过赤道。是的，但作为船长，被他的船员浸入水中对库克来说看起来太糟糕了。我会，我的意思是，在这种情况下我会支付罚款，我想。哦，我会去浸人。
Would you? You'd be the man of the people. I wouldn't. I think the dunking would be an experience in and of itself, wouldn't it? Be an exciting experience. Yeah, maybe. Maybe. So you forfeit
你会吗？你会成为人民的男人。我不会。我认为浸入本身就是一种体验，不是吗？会是一次令人兴奋的体验。是的，也许。也许。所以你没收了
four days grog if you don't do the dunking they do the dunking they keep going they go all the way down to rio again a sort of fairly standard stop on this sort of route they're received very suspiciously at rio so they say you know we're we are on our way to observe the transit of venus they give exactly the same explanation of the astronomical details that we gave but you did yeah but the portuguese bizarrely aren't convinced no no they're very very suspicious they obviously the transit of Venus. They give exactly the same explanation of the astronomical details that we gave. But you did. Yeah. But the Portuguese bizarrely aren't convinced. No, no, they're very, very suspicious.
四天的朗姆酒，如果你不参加浸入仪式。他们进行了浸入仪式，他们继续前进，他们一直向下到达里约，这又是这类航线上相当标准的停靠。他们在里约受到非常怀疑的接待，所以他们说，你知道，我们正在前往观测金星凌日的路上。他们给出了和我们给出的关于天文细节完全一样的解释。但你确实……是的，但葡萄牙人奇怪地不相信。不，不，他们非常、非常怀疑。显然他们缺乏你对天文学的精通。他们确实。总之，他们能够安然无恙地离开，然后他们向下前往合恩角和火地岛。在路上，班克斯和库克闹了一点别扭，因为班克斯想在福克兰群岛停靠。嗯，你知道丹尼斯·撒切尔是怎么评价福克兰群岛的吗？几英里又几英里，什么都没有。是的。
They obviously lacked your facility with astronomy. They did. Anyway, they're able to get away unscathed and down they go towards Cape Horn and towards Tierra del Fuego. And on the way, Banks has a bit of a strop with Cook because Banks wanted to stop off at the Falkland Islands. Well, you know what Dennis Thatcher said of the Falkland Islands? Miles and miles bugger all. Yeah.
所以丹尼斯·撒切尔会非常像库克。他会是库克团队的。是的。然后他们到达了火地岛，不是吗？是的。我看到你关于那个落水的人做了笔记。是的。这是一个可怕的时刻。所以他被扫落水。正如你所说，他们不会游泳。他的水手同伴们不得不看着他，但他们帮不了他。库克写道，他们感到震惊，他可能在相当长的一段时间内保持清醒，以及他那无法挽回的处境所带来的恐惧。
So Dennis Thatcher would very much be a Cook. He'd be team Cook. Yeah. And then they reached Tierra del Fuego, don't they? Yes. And I see that you've made this note about the man who fell overboard. Yeah. It's a terrible moment. So he gets swept overboard. And as you said, they can't swim. And his fellow sailors have to watch him, but they can't help him. And Cook writes that they were appalled that he might continue sensible for a considerable time longer, and of the horror attending his irretrievable situation.
这能集中注意力吗？会。看着那个。所以现在他们有了第一次伟大的互动。我们正走向这一集的结尾，但我们应该谈谈他们与土著人民的第一次互动。因为他们在火地岛登陆，遇到了火地岛人，我想他们现在已经灭绝了，对吧？我的意思是，如果人们可以灭绝，我不确定这是不是正确的词。火地岛人似乎不再存在了，我想是因为他们被
Does that concentrate the mind? It would. Watching that. So now they have their first great interaction. We're moving towards the end of this episode, but we should have their first interaction with indigenous peoples. Because they land at Tierra del tierra del fuego and they meet the fuegians who are now i think extinct aren't they i mean if people can be extinct i'm not sure that's the right word the fregians don't really exist anymore i think because they were ravaged by
疾病蹂躏了。是的，所以所有19世纪的恐怖都降临在他们身上。他们从出生起就会用海豹油覆盖自己，这会让你的父母覆盖你，你余生都会被油覆盖。但缺点是你闻起来很臭。嗯，只有当你来自英国时，这才是缺点。我的意思是，对他们来说，他们都习惯了。是的，不，不，绝对是。你的缺点，如果你在公司里，这是一种缺点，我想可以公平地说，如果你在国际公司里，而火地岛人通常不是，但这是一个没有被……我的意思是，麦哲伦显然访问过它，但没有多少人去过那里，在英国，人们仍然认为火地岛人是巨人。所以这是库克去发现他们是否是巨人的原因之一，他们不是，他们只是
disease yeah so all the the full 19th century horrors visited on them they would cover themselves with seal oil from the moment they were born and it would keep your parents would cover you and you would be covered in oil for the rest of your life but the downside is you were very foul smelling well it's only a downside if you're you know from england i mean for them they're all used to it yes no no no absolutely your downsides it's a downside if you're in company i think it's fair to say if you're an international company which generally the fuegians aren't but it's it's a place that hasn't been i mean mcgillan obviously visited it but not many people have been there and it's still believed back in england that the fuegians are giants so this is one of the things that cook has gone is to discover whether they're giants or not and they're not they just
到处闻起来有油和脂肪的味道。班克斯对此非常感兴趣，我的意思是，他去收集植物，库克对此有点嗤之以鼻。所以库克报告说，九点钟，他们回到船上，带回了几种植物、花卉等，其中大多数在欧洲是未知的。仅此而已，构成了它们的全部价值。所以他印象不深。但班克斯很享受与当地人的互动，不是吗？他说他和他的团队受到了许多粗鲁的友谊标志的欢迎。理查德·霍夫在他的库克传记中说，不清楚那些标志是什么，但很有可能它们指的是赤裸的男性火地岛人在互相问候时，特别是在互相问候时，玩弄他们的阴茎。是的。所以我认为班克斯会
kind of go around smelling of yeah of oil and fat banks is all over it i mean he's he's off kind of collecting plants and cook is a little bit sniffy about this. So Cook reports, at nine, they returned on board, bringing with them several plants, flowers, et cetera, most of them unknown in Europe. And in that alone consisted their whole value. So he's not very impressed. But Banks quite enjoys the interactions with the locals, doesn't he? He says he and his team were received with many uncouth signs of friendship. And Richard Hoff in his biography of Cook says, it's not clear what those signs were, but it's very possible they may refer to the naked male Fuegans making much play with their penises, especially when greeting one another. Yeah. So I think Banks would have
喜欢那个。库克印象不深。有趣的是，在这一点上，库克对我们现在可能称之为人类学的东西没有真正的兴趣。一种认为他遇到的人不仅值得研究，而且可能具有任何价值的感觉。所以他认为他们完全超出了文明的范围，他们穿着这种恶臭的脂肪，他们似乎过着可怕的生活。而事实上，他们实际上过着辉煌的生活，因为他们跟随，你知道，有很多鸟，很多食物，季节性的，他们可以迁徙。随着时间的推移，库克对此的理解会演变。我认为这就是他如此有趣的地方。有一次，一些火地岛人来到
enjoyed that. Cook is not impressed. And what's interesting is that at this point, Cook has no real interest in what we might now call anthropology. A sense that the people he's meeting are not simply worthy of kind of study, but that they might have any value. So he sees them as absolutely kind of beyond the pale that they're wearing this stinking fat, that they seem to have a terrible life. Whereas in fact, they actually have a brilliant life because they're following, you know, there's lots of birds, lots of food, seasonal, they can migrate. And in due course, Cook's understanding of this will evolve. And that's what's so interesting about him, I think. There's a point where some of the Fuegans come
船上，不是吗？有一个火地岛人，他们认为他可能是驱魔人什么的，因为每当有什么东西引起他的注意时，他就会对自己大喊大叫，但库克和他的船员随机认为可能有什么咒语，因为他对所见所闻感到不安。所以那里有一点误解。是的，但同样，随着库克航行的进行，会发生什么，他会变得越来越着迷于这些理解世界、宇宙等的不同方式。现在在火地岛，对他来说似乎是不可理解的野蛮，随着时间的推移，他会变得更有兴趣。这是库克船长故事中真正引人注目的事情之一，只是为了预告，
on the ship, isn't there? And there's one of the Fuegans who they think may be an exorcist or something, because whenever anything catches his attention attention he shouts aloud to himself but randomly cook and his crew think that there's maybe some sort of incantation because he's disturbed by what he's seeing so there's a slight incomprehension there yeah but again what will happen in due course over the course of cook's voyages is that he will become increasingly fascinated by these kind of expressions of different ways of understanding the world, the cosmos and whatever. And what now in Tierra del Fuego seems to him incomprehensible barbarism, in time he will become much more interested in it. This is one of the really striking things about the Captain Cook story, just to anticipate,
当你阅读他的日记和他对所遇到的人的看法时，他比18世纪殖民主义的刻板印象要开明得多。绝对是。绝对是。所以他在火地岛，他也许是人们可能认为的狭隘的18世纪英国人的刻板印象，对国外和外国人嗤之以鼻。但随着接下来发生的事情，这种情况会改变，因为从火地岛，
is that when you read his journals and what he made of the people that he met, he is much more open-minded than the sort of stereotype of an 18th century embodiment of colonialism. Absolutely. Absolutely. And so he's on Tierra del Fuego, and he is kind of the stereotype, perhaps, of what people might think of a blinkered 18th century Englishman, contemptuous of abroad and foreigners. But over the course of what will follow, this will change because from Tierra del Fuego,
库克可以，你知道，他离开了大西洋，他可以进入太平洋。在他面前是这段非凡的旅程，这将是我们下一集的主题。当我们到达塔希提岛，我们到达新西兰，我们到达澳大利亚。所以汤姆，我们有自己的船友，不是吗？“历史就是这样”俱乐部的成员。我们非常把他们视为我们的船员，我们的同志。所以汤姆，他们可以马上听下一集，就在现在，就在这一分钟。他们可以身处太平洋。
Cook can, you know, he's left the Atlantic and he can go into the Pacific. And ahead of him lies this extraordinary journey, which will be the subject of our next episode. When we get to Haiti, we get to New Zealand and we get to Australia. So Tom, we have shipmates of our own, don't we? Members of the Rest Is History Club. We regard them very much as our crew, as our comrades. So Tom, they can listen to the next episode right away, right now, this very minute. They can be out in the Pacific.
正如我所说，他们可以前往澳大利亚和新西兰。各种刺激即将到来。但如果人们还没有登上那艘特定的船，他们可以在restishistorypod.com上这样做，否则他们就只能等到周四了。在火地岛。是的。那里非常冷。没错。
They can be heading for Australia and New Zealand as I speak. There's all kinds of thrills coming. But if people have not embarked on that particular ship, they can do so at restishistorypod.com, because otherwise they will just have to wait till Thursday. At Tierra del Fuego. Yeah. Where it's very cold. Exactly.
你会在火地岛待到周四。但如果你想继续前进，现在就在restishistorypod.com上这样做。这非常符合18世纪英国那种礼貌和商业的精神，不是吗，汤姆？确实。这就是我们的全部意义。带着这个重磅炸弹，我们说非常感谢。我们下次见。
You'll be on Tierra del Fuego till Thursday. But if you want to move on, do so now at restishistorypod.com. And that is very much in the spirit, the polite and commercial spirit of 18th century England, isn't it, Tom? It is. It's what we're all about. And on that bombshell, we say thank you very much. We'll see you next time.
再见。哟吼。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐就是这样》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前……这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Goodbye. Yo-ho. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。哟吼。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《余下的就是娱乐》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕后真相，告诉您它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先体验，请加入我们。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。